we really need to keep seeing her bio we
need to keep oh I didn't notice that
it's where that you did don't hurt to do
that are you an anime stuff you jerk off
to anime I'm not no and I'm also not
answering
[Music]
hey buddy thanks for coming over
yeah I really appreciate it you got
through the gate okay they you mean the
parking lot of the building that we
shoot these uh yeah I got through and I
parked here if you want afterwards we'll
take out the garden I'm growing some
great tomatoes not gar grab a couple
really industrial this this cartoon do
you like uh world World War two
propaganda films yeah no I do I
definitely have a fan of that stuff
well this one is a made in 1934 okay in
1936 the US and Japan
their naval treaty was ending right
things are getting a little tense there
I don't feel I never badly it didn't go
great I don't remember anything we
dropped some bombs on them at some point
but baby ones uh so this is tiny ones so
this is a propaganda film by the
Japanese by the Japanese yeah okay
that's your guy sorry as being a white
person it's more comfortable for me to
watch that side of it hold on okay
you're gonna see Felix with Kat and then
it used to be like sticky okay and
Mickey Mouse is uh the American in this
now my gut is that Walt Disney didn't
sign off on some of this probably not
okay okay good you trying to get that
out there and roll it Thank You Bo it I
didn't say thanks for coming my house
but uh hey man it's not your house this
is my house why would my kid be starting
[Music]
19:36 mm-hmm that's when the treaty ends
Island tropical island birds
everything's normal
everything's normal it's great flying
around really flying around yeah
quite an establishing shot obviously
just people having fun there's some
crusty Japanese okay so this is Japan
like all is great
yep thing first at the end is a little
yeah I mean that guy should be in prison
but the rest are like hey all the Bali
so they just having a good time but
again bothering nobody here at Turtles
seen better days
do you hear that noise yeah oh no why is
it that's not good
those aren't seagulls oh no everybody's
scared what were they doing nothing
they're just hanging out having a good
time
oh so Mickey Mouse is America Mickey
Mouse 1936 so it's subtle so Mickey
Mouse they're saying writing another
Mouse playing oh he's just throwing his
I wish I wish I knew what this said but
I think it's just used toilet paper well
that's that's upsetting on a lot of
levels and then why is Fuchs a cat on
the side of Japan you tell me you get
Felix always had an eye towards history
and that's how we take down America
oh so dark is but bombs bombs nope
Mickey's a real Satanist yeah it's
happening we called in the other bats
like The Wizard of Mickey
oh no snake it's America of American
snakes are coming this is who you're one
of these am i yep this is one and the
crocodiles obviously America it's like
we have nature on our side nothing good
but parts web nature they get a clam
yeah so obviously oh so we can okay
bombings okay
uh-oh snakes are here so the machine-gun
snakes yeah there oh that guy's gone is
gone
Mickey Mickey nightmare who took a with
you Oh Mickey classic girl snatching
Mickey Mouse uh ah book into the book so
now this is like I I don't know who it
is like it's like an ancient Japanese
character right myth sort of guy so
meanwhile this is what we did during the
war the nation of making a mice I
believe he just said okay yeah he did
say okay and I was and now they so now
they're bringing all these characters
now they're bringing all the class all
hands on deaths right everyone's out for
the big battle and that's a good guy
pictures
so they're coming strong like this might
bard that's how you use bombs yeah card
him around that guy should be up front
and then he's got the box I and I'm not
really legitimately not rooting for
either side but so far my money is on
the evil Mickey yeah the the Jack we are
bringing the single turtles to a mouse
fight the team of the snakes is probably
gonna do that yeah yeah
anyway here's your gun snakes whoa that
you can shoot those right out of bat
mouths well what do you don't worry
we've got stapler removers oh he just uh
doesn't seem to care huh well look he's
on a narrow dusting those bombs away
with his penis it's a sparrow oh I'd say
you do it
[Music]
Oxygen's got to be hard to come by up
there yeah about time let's do this come
on Mickey this is yeah fight I wish I
was it oh my god could you imagine
upgrade it without it I don't wanna had
fought Japan ah don't worry the crabs
have the stapler removers and these guys
have a pencil
[Music]
snakes yep we've got very good snakes
then I was shooting at anybody
no but others had is a guy with a mug
man open head get in my stomach oh my
I've got cookies for brains what has
happened okay
I mean that's a good weapon to have oh
[Music]
no America what happened he tread on him
Oh loser oh god she's legis Mickey
that's not good
uh-oh oh they're all just Oh No Oh what
did they do to him they get melka
seltzer and Diet Coke
that's right Mickey Wow we're losing
this this is not going good
[Music]
come on come on Mickey get much bigger
know what I went through the ground he's
in hell
he is in hell where's the devil the
devil always wanted a crack at you
Mickey that's sad now he's back in the
house are you ready for the box oh no
Jesus Christ nerve agents oh she's great
she's awful
she's the worst of all over stop
laughing you made him an old man
old mouse Oh
now Dave yeah I don't know much yeah
this isn't how the war went right now
wait for the nuke to go off okay right
well I think this is a celebration oh no
what the hell that says I still can't
figure our food it's too long
no this isn't too long are we gonna be
here hold the whole harvest is nine
hours do we really need to keep seeing
her by now we need to keep oh I didn't
notice that it's where that you did
don't do that are you an anime stuff you
jerk off to anime I'm not no and I'm
also not answering them this is the
first anime girl but of course the
natural ending alright well how do you
feel about anything not good about
anything
overall it's a genital negative so you
know anyway the Japanese want the war he
based on that cartoon which was very
real mm-hm so there's the the box
there's like an old man who lives in a
box it's like a Japanese can we make a
cartoon of Walt Disney watching that
cartoon they turned Mickey old this is
anthrax they're giving Mickey right here
Walt huh well normal normal stuff as
usual
[Music]